-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show"!
This is it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, earlier today,
President Biden and
Russian President Vladimir Putin
finally met for their big summit
in Geneva, Switzerland.
Yep. It was pretty much
the opposite of
the "Friends" reunion.
Yeah, Biden and Putin
met at this Swiss estate.
Yeah.
-Ooh!
-You may recognize it as
the haunted asylum
in every horror movie.
Actually, Putin found
the place on his favorite
house-rental site, AirKGB.
-Oh.
-Well, Biden and Putin
both arrived
within 20 minutes of each other.
Here they are
shaking hands outside.
[ Indistinct shouting,
camera shutters clicking ]
-Yeah. Meanwhile,
Trump was watching on TV like...
-♪ Don't you remember you
told me you loved me, baby? ♪
-Once the president
stepped inside,
they sat down
for another photo op.
Take a look at this. Yeah.
Looked like two dads waiting for
their daughters to finish
trying on prom dresses.
They're like, "That looks great,
honey, yeah."
Putin looks like
he's trying to remember
which one of those books
opens up the trapdoor.
He's like, "Okay, this one..."
Say hello to the sharks,
Mr. Biden.
There are some piranhas that
were -- Hold on."
Then Biden and Putin
got down to business,
where it was just them,
a red table,
and Jada Pinkett Smith.
And that's what
I'm talking about.
That's when it gets --
That's when they mean --
Let's get down to business.
Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The meeting was
expected to be five hours
but lasted only half that time.
Not a great sign
when your summit
is barely longer than
"Peter Rabbit 2."
But after the meeting, the two
leaders agreed to keep in touch.
When Biden said,
"I'll give you my e-mail,"
Putin said, "I already have your
e-mail and password.
And Venmo.
Don't worry about it."
And this is nice.
The White House
said Biden gave Putin
a pair of
custom aviator sunglasses.
Yeah. Putin says he's excited
to wear the aviators
back home in Russia, where the
sun's out twice a year.
Biden also gave Putin a
crystal sculpture of a bison.
Yeah. A crystal bison.
Weirdly enough, Crystal Bison
is also one of Trump's
old girlfriends.
-Really?
-Yeah. She's...
Oh, yeah.
-He paid her off -- $130,000.
-130 grand, yeah.
-Yeah.
After the meeting,
Putin held a press conference
and was asked if he thinks
the U.S. and Russia
will now have
a better relationship.
And listen to his response.
-What?
-Wow!
-What?!
-That's actually an
excerpt from Putin's new book,
"Chicken Soup
for the Russian Soul."
-Oh.
-"There's no happiness in life."
-Yeah.
It sounds like the slogan
for Russian Applebee's.
Switching gears,
according to an annual list
that was just released,
New Jersey is America's
best state to live in.
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah! Come on! Yes!
[ Crowd booing, cheering ]
Yay! Yeah!
-[ Laughs ]
-Yeah! Come on!
-Wow!
Yeah, the key factors
they considered were
cost of living,
quality of education,
and access to gabagool.
-Oh!
♪♪
-Finally, speaking of
the Garden State,
yesterday,
at a New Jersey water park,
a water slide
actually caught on fire.
Take a look at this thing.
Holy!
-Oh!
-There it is --
the best state to live in,
ladies and gentlemen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
A water slide...
Meanwhile, there was still
a 16-year-old lifeguard
at the top of the slide saying,
"You can go.
You can go.
[ Drumbeat ]
[ Laughs ] You can go.
You can go. You can go.
You can go. Yeah.
You can go.
That's right -- the thing
just burst into flames,
which is why the slide's new
name is Gender Reveal Party.